It's so disturbing to me
that we live in a society that desperately wants to skip our period.
So desperately
that we're basically just rebranding the Plan B pill
into a skip your period pill.
This was an actual ad that popped up on my TikTok feed.
Got a hot date?
I want that pesky period get in the way.
You got a vacation coming up.
You don't need that stupid thing called a period.
Your period gives you hell because your hormones are out of balance
and your diet and lifestyle could be better.
Audience, you silly goose.
News flash. Chemically suppressing your period
is just going to kick the can down the road
and make your hormone problems even worse.
I hate to break it to you,
but if your man's doesn't wanna touch you when you're on your period,
you're not dating a man,
you're dating a little bitch.